What is fasted a good idea?
So there are genetic steps that when we see those steps, especially when we look at
a whole cancer profile, that we do recommend doing some sort of fasted.
Now with our cancer patients, we don't recommend that they do more than a 24 hour fast.
And that's specific for cancer and that has to do with up regulating the M-tore pathway after 24 hour
fast and up regulating. So increase release of growth hormone products and stuff like that.
So IGF-1 is increased after 24 hour fast and that can be detrimental to a person that has
active cancer. If a person doesn't have cancer, fasting can be a good idea.
But you also have to look at other core morbidities. If a person is dealing with hypoglycemia,
you've got to be very careful of fasting because it could make your hypoglycemia worse for a period of
time. But so it gets a little bit more complicated. There's other ways to do fasting other than a
complete water fast meeting that you're not taking in any food. You're only drinking water. You're
not drinking juice, coffee tea. And you're doing that for X amount of hours, whether it's 24 hour
faster, 48 hour faster, a whole week faster. And in any fasting, we always recommend that you go
really slow. The other type of fasting is what's called time restricted eating. So you're just
picky at window during the day that you're eating. And you start off with a fairly large window.
Maybe you're going to pick your window between noon and six. You have a six hour window that
you're going to eat between noon and six every day. And then at six o'clock p.m., you're not going
to eat anything until 12 noon the next day. So you're getting an 18 hour fast. And you let's say
you do that three days a week. That's time restricted eating. You might not do it every day.
You might do it Monday, Wednesday, Friday. There can be benefit to that. You can short up the window
even more so if you've done it that for a period of time. And then you can short up the window to three
to six. And now you're over three hour window that you're eating. And that gives you a 21 hour fast
all that every day that you do that maybe three days a week again as an example. That's called time
restricted eating. Some people do time restricted eating daily. You don't want to start that way.
You want to always do any type of fast. You want to start start my own. So I could never done any fast
eat right now. You know, this is brand new to you. You always start with something very mild. So that's
the way to start with a fast. So if you've never done any fast, you certainly don't start with a 24 hour
fast or more than that because it could be too much. I always go slow with anything, especially if you
don't have a practitioner that you're working with, you've got to make sure that you're going slow.
It's a good idea too to get a little decommeter. You could pick those up at Target or Walgreens.
It's a finger print test to measure your blood glucose. You know what your blood glucose
tanking in a hypoglycemic state if you've never fasted before. That's the danger of doing that.
But again, back to the genetics, genetics doesn't give you specific, well, you should fast.
I personally believe fasting can be good for everybody unless you person has cancer.
They're in a caquexic state where they're losing weight uncontrollably, but most people in
fasting can be a really good thing to be doing. It can be very good for your health.